Let's see if we can calculate
4/3 minus 1/5
If you learn how to put them
I encourage you to pause the video and calculate the output
When you first consider the matter
It will appear to you
That our fractures have different sanctuaries
Thus, it may be unclear how to subtract 1/5 from 4/3
For their different positions
And how to put fractions with different denominators are rewriting the fractions
To two fractions of the same name
How can we find the same place for fractions?
Well, we'll find the common multiplier between the three and five
Ideally we will find the smallest common multiplier between the two properties
The three and five
How can we calculate that?
Well, we'll start with the two largest numbers
It is the five and we find its multiples
Until we reach a multiplication of the five, the division on the three is fully accepted
The five do not accept dividing the three
The ten can not be divided on the three fifteen can be divided by the three
In fact the fifteen are five hit three
Therefore, I can write both of these fractions
As a number on the fifteenth
Thus, how will it become 4/3 when written as a number on the fifteen
Well, in order to get fifteen in the place instead of three
We beat in five
And if we hit the place in five
We did not want to change the value of the fracture
We must hit the rugs in five
Well, I'll hit the rugs in five
Four hit five equals twenty
If, fraction 4/3 represents the same fraction 20/15
Okay
Now how can we rewrite the fraction 1/5 as a number on fifteen
If so, we will have the number fifteen in the denominator
In order to get fifteen in the place instead of five, we hit in three
If we hit the place in three
We will also multiply the rugs in three
If three hit
One hit three equals three
We were therefore able to rewrite the wording of Question 4/3 minus 1/5
To the formula 20/15 minus 3/15
Now, the issue has become clearer
How much is the sum of the sum?
Well, the output will be a certain number of fifteen parts
We have 20/15
We will take 3/15
If, the result becomes
If we had twenty of something and took three of them
We will get seventeen of this thing
In this case we are talking about the fifteen
Consequently, the result will be 17/15
And if we want to write the fraction as fractional number
The division of the seventeen to fifteen equals one
The rest are two
Thus, the fraction is equal to 2/15 1 to solve another example
To see if we can calculate 7/10 minus 5/8
Minus 5/8
I encourage you to turn off the video
To see if you can calculate it yourself
Well, like we did before
We have different sanctuaries here
We need to rewrite it in the same place
In this way we can perform the subtraction
Well, what is the common multiplier between the numbers ten and eight
Ideally, what is the smallest common multiplier between the two properties
It is not necessary to find the smaller common multiplier
But it will make it simpler
Well, we'll start with the largest number in the list
Then we find multiples
Until we reach a multiplier that is fully divided over the other number
Here we look for a smaller common multiplier for the ten that can be divided by eight
Well, the ten do not accept the division on the eight completely or not on the twenty
And not on the thirty, while the forty are divided by eight
Forty of the ten complications and also of the eight complications
The 40 is the smallest common multiplier between the ten and eight
Thus, we can rewrite both fractions
As a number on the forty
If the number becomes forty minus
Number on forty
Minus the number of forty equals the number of forty
7/10 is a number of forty, what is this number?
Well, let's get forty in the place instead of ten
We beat in four
We will also do the same thing in the rugs
We multiply the rites in four and seven hit four equals eighteen
Thus, fraction 7/10 represents the same fraction 28/40
Now we will do the same thing with the other fraction
In order to get forty in the place instead of eight
We beat the place in five
Eight hit five equals forty
If we hit the place in five
We will also multiply the rugs in five
Five hit five equals twenty-five
If 7/10 minus 5/8 equals exactly
28/40 minus 25/40 and now became more pronounced
We will get a certain number of 40 parts
If we find twenty-eight of the forty, we have taken twenty-five of them
How much is the rest of the forty?
Well, the rest is three parts of forty
28/40 minus 25/40 equals 3/40
Twenty-eight minus twenty-five equals three .. And it ended
7/10 minus 5/8 equals 3/40